good morning John in 2007 a group of
people got together and we hacked
YouTube there's a lot always put up but
I think that that's the simplest we used
all the tricks that we've learned as
youtubers to help our videos get more
views and we use those tricks more than
we would ever have used those tricks
normally and while this would have felt
underhanded and maybe even a little bit
dirty if we were just doing it to grow
our video views instead it felt awesome
because we were doing it for charity
unfortunately Mike Huckabee's attempts
to hack the Republican nomination for
president interfere with our taking over
the entire first page or the most
discussed page but in the end our hack
was more successful than his the product
continued annually though every year
sitting a little bit less subversive a
little bit less underground a little bit
more illegitimate and more and more
YouTube actually wanted to work together
with us to promote it and I'm like
YouTube what's up that's not what this
about you're supposed to be some
faceless monolith that we have to work
through the backdoors to get to the top
you're not supposed to be like hi my
name is Rama and this is Margaret and
Bing and Chris and we're all gonna help
you get to the front page of YouTube and
you don't have to subvert us we want to
help but what I just realized John is
that often the most elegant hacks have
elements of social engineering the real
con relies on somebody weaseling their
way into the organization so that they
can do stuff from the inside and let me
tell you we weaseled her way like no
other we went from having to use every
trick in the book to get a few more
thousand views on YouTube to YouTube
literally banging down our door to get
involved why is that well I think it's
two reasons one because I think
everybody wants to help and they're just
looking for a way like we all know that
the world is broken but it's so hard to
figure out how to get involved without
feeling really just depressed about the
whole thing people wanted to be
meaningful but they don't want to feel
bad about it they don't want to hate
their entire lives just because they're
trying to do something good and I think
that everybody knows that that's what
the project for awesome is for but
really the obvious and real reason why
YouTube wants to be involved in this is
because they see how powerful this
community is and how much more powerful
it could be if we all shared these
resources use the power of our community
and of their platform and mixed it
together for true epicness so honestly
what we're doing here is hacking for
charity harder than ever before we
hacked wheezy waiters chest hair we
hacked John's fear of heights and we
hacked YouTube from the inside out I
mean how else could we change the logo
get 40 front page video features and
have access to a team
YouTube employees to plan a ridiculously
fancy live show and yeah I think next
year we're gonna do it a little bit
differently but there's no denying that
this has been the most successful
project for awesome ever six hundred
thousand comments on over three thousand
project for awesome videos with a total
running time of over forty hours in
total video views' of over ten million
and whereas previous project for awesome
have been all about raising awareness
through creation of videos this year we
also raised money over $100,000 in small
donations and a total of over a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars that of
course meaning that the vast majority of
that money was raised by small donations
from individuals like you thousands of
individuals giving what they can adding
up to a huge huge number
I think I'm proud of the project for
awesome more than I'm proud of anything
else I've ever done the quality of the
videos produced for the project keeps
going up the total number of people
working on it keeps going up and I'm so
impressed by the way that people work
together because they want to work
together and they everyone feels like
there's sort of equal part in this thing
and more than anything the way that I
feel like we're all people being people
no matter where we are what our
circumstances are which I think has
implications way beyond the project for
awesome thank you to all of you thank
you John and John I will see you on
Wednesday and screentime there was one
video that didn't get a lot of promotion
during the project for awesome because
it was uploaded a little late but man
are you going to weep
Sean's uncultured project video this
year you should click and check it out
right now